isabelle c'est une tempête
exceptionnelle qui a traversé le nord de
la france et qui a frappé paris ce matin
au lever du jour
c'est vrai que sur ces régions météo
france n'avait jamais vu ça dans la
mesure où généralement ce type de
phénomène circule un peu plus au nord
affectant donc plus souvent l'angleterre
que la france mais ce matin c'est
vraiment une dépression exceptionnelle
qui s'est organisée un peu comme une
tornade et qu'elle circulait très
rapidement puisque elle a traversé
l'atlantique en 24 heures à 4 heures
elle était déjà sur la bretagne elle
abordait la bretagne est à 10 heures
elle quittait déjà le pays est officiel
et sur la pologne
il lui a suffi que de six heures pour
ravager complètement le nord du pays
avec des vents d'une extrême violence et
isobel ce soir météo france incite
chacun à la plus grande prudence parce
que ce n'est pas tout à fait terminée
tout à fait prudent ce soir et cette
nuit dans la mesure où un autre
phénomène est en train de balayer le
pays en suivant la même trajectoire
ça aussi c'est rare ce phénomène est
accompagné de vents un peu moins violent
c'est vrai mais quand même 120
kilomètres à l'heure les rafales étant
associé à des nuages d'orage donc le
danger est réel
et puis il faut également savoir que un
autre coup de vent est prévu dans la
nuit de lundi à mardi prochain sur les
côtes de l'aquitaine
donc un seul conseil si vous en avez la
possibilité restez chez vous et nous
vous retrouvons isabelle à la fin de ce
journal évidemment